since I last saw you your fantastic
performance in moonlights moonlight and
the Oscars it is now stuff of legend the
the the end when they read out the wrong
name and we've talked about it on the
show before and Warren Beatty's being
here we asked him what would a doll and
everything but you were in the middle of
it so you did end up on stage you did go
up in the end eventually yeah I mean
yeah it took me a while because I was
kind of glued to my seat in just shock
and then our producer dragged me onstage
so but is it a nice way to win to have
disappointment first then go I think it
is in a way because there's never been a
moment like that before or since the
Oscars so I think it's kind of cool
and whenever always remembers that make
everyone remember when you're on stage
you were looking out at the audience and
we've shown this picture before it's a
great picture it's everyone matter Eamon
like a fly I could find him you Michelle
one just looked shocked but I don't
think anyone is quite as concerned
really was I Merrill seems ice bother
than you was composed I honestly thought
I'm seconds away from running up on this
stage and kicking somebody's ass because
I thought some [ __ ] was going down
so that's what I thought you know I
thought like we were in the middle of
like somebody trying to hijack something
yeah and not and then I knew she had
already said yes by the way to rampage
so she was on stage I was like don't
mess with my girl
[Music]